good morning  as you know we had invited our british  friends  to remove the problematic parts of their  draft internal  market bill by the end of september  this draft bill is by its very nature  a breach of the obligation of good faith  laid down in the withdrawal agreement  moreover  if adopted as is it will be in full  contradiction to the protocol of ireland  northern ireland the deadline lapsed  yesterday  the problematic provisions have not been  removed  therefore this morning the commission  has decided  to send a letter of formal notice to the  uk government  this is the first step in an  infringement procedure  the letter invites the uk government to  send  its observations within a month  and besides this the commission will  continue to work hard  towards a full and timely implementation  of the withdrawal agreement we stand by  our commitments  thank you  [Music]  you